michel fize bonjour bonjour et bienvenue
dans la matinale de rtl france ravi de
vous vous retrouvez en chair et en os
sur notre plateau alors la souffrance
endurée par beaucoup de français ce
qu'elle peut amplifier leur colère
déclenché un nouveau grand mouvement
social à l'image de celui des gilets
jaunes alors je crois qu'il faut
rappeler que la crise sanitaire a masqué
et continue de masquer toutes les autres
crises et évidemment en premier lieu
cette crise sociale qui frappe de
nombreux français aujourd'hui vous
l'avez rappelé la pauvreté continue de
s'amplifier il y à entre 10 et 12
millions de de pauvres aujourd'hui dans
qui perçoivent à peu près 1000 euros par
mois 1 milles 63 euros pour être très
précis et puis il ya la précarité 1 il
ya des choses par exemple qu'on ne dit
pas près de 20% des français vivent
aujourd'hui à découvert et le nombre
d'allocataires rsa donc je rappelle en
moyenne 500 euros par mois 1 continue de
grimper depuis depuis le commencement de
la crise alors moi se pose la question
des besoins on a beaucoup parlé des
besoins essentiels et non essentiels je
crois que maintenant il faudrait pouvoir
distinguer les besoins essentiels et les
besoins vitaux voilà se loger dans des
conditions décentes sans avoir froid car
beaucoup de français ont froid dans leur
loge leur logement se nourrir de façon
convenable un pouvoir manger les 5
fruits et légumes qui sont devenus un
luxe un regard des les ailes et les
fruits c'est entre 4 euros et 10 euros
le kilo les légumes acheter un kilo de
tomates mâché 4 euros payés donc là on a
une sorte de
2,2 de confrontation entre la
macroéconomie servi par le pouvoir
exécutif qui nous parle de croissants 6%
à venir qui parle de 230 milliards
versés aux entreprises en termes dette
mais tout ça ça ne dit rien ça ne dit
rien aux français qui eux regardent au
plus près voilà cette question qui à mon
sens devrait être une priorité de
l'action politique j'ai rêvé un peu je
me disais si j'étais président à la
manière du jard
le normand eh bien je placerais encore
une fois la question du pouvoir d'achat
comme priorité de l'action politique
voilà parce que les français sont pas
intéressés par les questions ou moins
intéressé par les questions d'insécurité
par les questions d'immigration c'est
très très loin voilà c'est ce qui est
dans le dans le portefeuille alors sur
la question de la suite on dit que les
mêmes causes produisent les mêmes effets
à condition que les conditions quand
même sociale soit identique ou
équivalentes c'est pas tout à fait le
cas puisque bon la crise sanitaire quand
même bouleversé esprit freine peut-être
un certain nombre incertain et d'ardeur
mais encore une fois en 2021 on conserve
le cocktail explosif qui avait conduit à
la révolte des gilets jaunes en 2018 à
l'exécutif peut-il selon vous conseillez
l'action contre le virus là l'action
contre l'insécurité et celle contre les
inégalités qui sont également
territoriales ces inégalités je pense
que le rôle d'un pouvoir politique c'est
d'aller dans tous les sens en même temps
quand effectivement tout est aujourd'hui
menacé bon la crise sanitaire est
évidemment une priorité mais je pense
que une saine économie en est une autre
et puis que tous les français puissent
vivre effectivement décemment parce
qu'encore une fois il n'est pas normal
aujourd'hui que certains français ne
puisse pas faire les trois repas par
jour n'est pas accès aux eaux cinq
fruits et légumes dont on nous parle
quotidiennement sur les ondes ou ou sur
les écrans et puis se déplacer parce que
se déplaçait aussi en voiture
dans les zones est évidemment où il ya
peu de transport collectif c'est aussi
c'est aussi un droit donc je pense que
le futur président ou les candidats
ferait sans doute bien pour évidemment
satisfaire ses besoins vitaux des
français
de rajouter encore une fois
l'amélioration du pouvoir d'achat des
uns et des autres dans leur programme
merci beaucoup michel fize pour notre
édito ce matin en direct sur arte france
merci